uh good morning everyone and can i
welcome you to this meeting of
development
control committee a at mid-suffolk
district council
first of all i just want to remind
everyone of some of the domestic
arrangements
please can i please can you ensure that
microphones are muted
when you're not speaking please do not
interrupt
other speakers members are reminded not
to use the messaging or chat
function during the meeting unless it is
to report a pecuniary or non-pecuniary
interest or to notify myself
that you wish to make a proposal members
are reminded that they should not have
alternative communication lines
open during the meeting i other teams
chats
or use the emojis and that if you are
contacted by a third party during an
application can you please bring this to
the attention of our legal advisor
if you are attending the meeting to
speak today uh welcome
but if you do persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
additionally you'll be invited to speak
and ask questions by myself
and uh sorry addition you'll be invited
to speak and ask questions by myself
uh and by using the hands up function
and uh we'll be using an e-voting system
for the meeting
if you are experiencing any poor
connection issues
and the first instance can i suggest you
please turn off your camera
if this does not work turn off maybe all
incoming videos and these options can be
found
on the three dots at the top of the
information bar
i'd like to remind everyone present this
meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewings
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded except where there are
confidential or exempt
items if you make a representation to
the meeting you'll be deemed by the
council to have consented to have been
recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you're also consenting to being recorded
by the council
and to the possible use of those sound
recordings for webcasting
and or future training purposes the
council members of the public and the
press
may record film photograph or broadcast
this meeting
when the public and press are not
lawfully excluded
just like to run through uh some of the
people that are with us today
so first of all we have ian de prez
who's our legal advisor
good morning ian good morning
robert carmichael who's our governance
officer good morning robert
good morning to you um uh now i have on
my list
uh uh uh gemma walker and john paytman g
the area planning managers good morning
morning chair good morning um now is
philip
bill with us for this meeting i don't
believe no i don't so no he's on my list
as possibly attending um
avril goody uh catherine hale uh are the
case officers good morning
good morning both here good
thank you and sam harvey uh good morning
from suffolk county council highways
good morning sam
is sam with us
all right i don't believe sam has joined
yet okay
but she is due to join us so i'm sure
she'll be here in a minute okay
for the applications before us today uh
we have uh
various ward members including um
i haven't got the list i don't think
that's in front of me is entirely
accurate um
uh maybe it is here barry councillor
barry humphries council
oliver and morrison council richard
mayer and councillor wendy turner
um in in missouri district council um if
you are the ward member you may
uh debate sorry you may participate in
the meeting
and have your say but you may not vote
on the applications before us
okay so i'm going to move on to the
agenda now
first item on the agenda apologies for
absence and substitutions do we have any
please
thank you chair we have no apologies or
substitutions
okay and we now need to take a roll call
for members present
i'll ask the governance officer to carry
that out please
thank you chair so if members could
please respond with their presence
counselor rachel ebern present counselor
john field
president councillor hicks present house
of sarah mansell
present counselor john
thank you chair all committee members
are present right thank you for that
okay and now agenda number two to
receive declarations of pecuniary or
non-pecuniary interest by members
are there any yes we have a few hands
they've gone up councillor mansell and
councillor miller
uh thank you chair i i just felt that
perhaps i need to declare a
non-pecuniary interest
as the event director of the yet to be
launched
chilton fields park run which uses some
of the
paths as part of the taylor wimpy
development
so that is the gender item first the
first item
um i'll declare non-peculiar interest
thank you thanks very much and
councillor muller
thank you chair i am the vice chair of
the stone market town council planning
committee and we've previously discussed
this case at that committee so it's a
non
non-pecuniary interest thank you
thank you are you happy with that yes
chair i'm quite happy those are properly
disclosed as non-peculiary interests but
no more than that thank you
thanks so much um declarations of
lobbying by members
um do we have any council mansell
oh that's a legacy hand sorry i'll take
it away
from any any lobbying no
none to declare okay any declarations of
personal site visits by members
none received okay thank you so that
takes us on to agenda item number five
which is the confirmation of the minutes
the meeting held on the 17th of february
2021
um are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes
no could i have a proposal for the
minutes and a second
please councillor muller proposing
post yes please check thank you and
councillor mayor seconding
thank you okay could i ask the
governor's office to now conduct an
electronic vote on that
please
thank you chair if members could please
go to the modern.gov app
and click the on to date onto today's
agenda and click the plus sign in the
top right hand corner
and click on the subsection for voting
and attendance
the vote will appear on that screen in a
light blue color
under the voting tab the vote is now in
progress
thank you chair that is unanimous eight
votes for and i believe council madison
has um got on to modern.gov so we don't
need to take his vote
verbally thank you very much okay so the
minister meeting have now been confirmed
and they'll be signed at the next
practical opportunity
thank you everyone okay agenda item
number six is to receive a notification
of petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme have we
received any please
none receive chair okay thank you um
so we'll move to the schedule of the
planning applications um first item
is item 7 a and our papers on page 23
northfield view phase 2b full away stone
market and i now ask the case officer
gemma walker
to introduce the application to the
committee over to you
thank you chair just if we could bear
with me a second while i get that
sharing up and running
as ever
there we go hopefully everybody comes
out
yeah we can see that thank you sorry
just nice to check
um thank you so this is an application
for reserve matters
on uh land at northfield view um which
is a
phase 2b of children lee's in stone
market
um we can see the approximate location
um
south of the a14 um in stone market
and then again zooming in slightly so
the a14 coming up to the top hill
junction
and stay market our way through here
and zooming in slightly we can just
start to see some of the road names on
the previous phases of development
coming through
and this is our current phase that we're
looking at in here and
coming across to the chilton fields
sports ground
this shows you the wider area so just to
confirm this is a
reserve matters following the outline
here for 600
and also a full application included the
road
which we can see running through the
center of our site down to the
roundabout and across through here
that was already approved as a full
application so what we're considering
today is the appearance scale layout and
landscaping of this proposal
and then we just to confirm this area to
the south would be the subject of a
future reserve matters but the area to
the north
is essentially the area that has been
granted and is under commencement
so looking at constraints just to
confirm we do have a listed building but
it is
somewhat separate from this part of the
site and was considered as part of the
wider site development
um and then we've got the assessment
boundaries for stone market
uh and across here for one house um you
can just see
this is the area of development at the
moment that has got existing reserve
matters consent
and you can see it's being built out at
the moment essentially
so looking at the layout plan um this
is a zoomed in version of the site so we
can see here the uh
existing and commence development to the
north which is phase 2a already approved
by reserve matters
we've got a community um orchard a local
equipped area for play
studs around the outside of the site and
public open space essentially either
side
the main road running through the site
and then across the bottom
and i propose residential development
for 100 houses
this is a zoomed in version which is
some of the detail on there
so we've got 100 houses with various
demarcations on here but i'll run
through those we've got essentially got
a plan for each of those
um which hopefully is a bit clearer so i
just thought that was helpful just as
the
uh detailed version so this is the
character plan this follows through from
the original master plan and then that's
been used to
run through the the site as you can see
up here on the existing part of the
development that's also
woodland view character area we carry
that through to the
external edge of the site is woodland
view we've got a neighborhood edge
and the church view um areas to the side
the area around the roundabout is a
specific parade um
and then the main central spine
character areas
and an inner link area so all have a
slightly different character area using
the same style of houses but with some
different design features just to
provide those navigation points by way
of running through the sites
looking down into affordable housing
this was um
agreed at reserve matters stage um
so the mix and tenure was uh subject to
section 106 but just to confirm the
location of them
they do there was a slight concern
initially over clustering but when we've
looked at that across the whole of the
site
affordable housing sorry strategic
housing are content with them
and you can see they are on different
streets so some onto the central area
some onto the private roads
either side so they are content that the
clustering of those is acceptable
to pick up on story heights we're
looking at predominantly two-story
buildings across the site
in the darker blue and then we've got
single-story garages
to properties which have carriages and
then we've got some in the
pinky purple color which would be two
and a half story buildings
but these are used to punctuate the
street scene
so at the entrance to the site and
particularly around the roundabout
which hopefully you can just see that's
the beginning of a suggestion that we
might replicate that around the round
about to create a specific
character area around that roundabout
then to go on to parking because i
appreciate this has been a concern for
members of various times
so all of the properties do have the
appropriate number of parking spaces
in accordance with suffolk parking
guidance there are still some with
triple parking
however in accordance with suffolk
parking guidance which does accept that
on some private drives
in appropriate circumstances these are
all on private drive so if i
briefly run through we've got some here
hopefully members can see you've got two
blue spaces followed by the green
garage essentially so there are triple
parking but these are all on this grey
area
of private road similarly here on the
private driveway
and around this area also all on the
private driveway
in addition this site does have visitor
spaces
adjacent to all of the triple parking
areas of particular note on that one
the proposal should provide 25 visitor
parking spaces it has in fact got 35
so it does provide an extra amount of
visitor parking particularly in the
areas
where the triple parking is situated and
i have confirmed with suffolk county
council highways that that is a
an acceptable approach both in the
combination of the private driveway
and in combination with extra visitor
parking in these locations to help stop
um movements in the highway affecting
the flow of traffic
to then pick up on that again slightly
in terms of boundary treatments you can
also see around these areas just
hopefully so it's it's like
light the orangey brown color is this um
timber new rail fencing so this would
also help prevent parking
other than in appropriate spaces and
again
you prevent the issue of parking on the
highway so overall that's the reason
we're content with the triple parking
despite
the you know the we wouldn't normally
accept that it is
in accordance with the allowance under
the parking guidance and in combination
with the treatment and the
visitor parking that's why we feel it
would be acceptable in this case
to move on to the street scenes um i
have provided members in the bundle
with the full um plans and elevations
but i wasn't planning on running through
those here for you because there are
quite a few
if there are specific ones members would
like to look at of course that's no
trouble
but hopefully that's available for you
in your packs and you can look but just
to pick up on the street scene
so we've got northfield woodland view
here so we've got
uh this is facing into the um
character areas to the matching
characters between 2a and 2b
sites in the woodland view area the
middle
street scene is um looking at the
sorry the corner turn of the buildings
so we can see the
um spine road and the buildings through
here and this would be overlooking the
play area that's on phase 2a so i
mentioned the local equipped area for
play at the north of this site
this is the street scene that would be
looking towards that
and then at the bottom we've got the um
essentially the diamond parade so we've
got the spine road coming in through
here with
uh essentially sort of stood on the
roundabout if you will
and then you can just see here
particularly the two and a half story
houses
that are proposed so you can see they're
not significantly higher
than we might expect or indeed a full
three story
but it does just offer that degree of
design feature to give you
a navigation point through and around
the site
to then take on to um
the site itself um hopefully you can see
in the bottom right hand corner of each
slide i've tried to suggest
roughly where we're looking so we're
still at the northern corner of our
current site
looking across it and hopefully this
snow is not too off-putting sorry that's
one of the things we encounter
occasionally
um sorry
why are we not moving on
there we go so then we've come down the
spine road and we're looking back up
we can see the housing under
construction here at the moment and then
looking across to the corner of the
children field sports club
and now we're looking again slightly
further around to see that existing
housing we were just looking at to our
right
and looking around across to the north
and then slightly further around again
across the sites
and then ones without snow so again
hopefully that's helpful
so this time we're on the far western
side of our site looking across and
again seeing the existing
uh development and again just looking
south this time
and across the site
and looking down now we can see the the
road under construction
and then we're at the essentially the
corner of the chilton field sports club
but looking across the site
so jen just to return to the layout plan
um
the design is considered to be in
keeping with the previous development on
parts of the site that's been approved
and indeed with the overall master plan
this follows
that reserve matters approval um and
permission for the central road and as
much as the master plan
overall in keeping with the existing
development across the wider science
and the layout appearance scale and
landscaping are considered to be
appropriate
and as such the recommendation is for
approval and that's on pages 37 and 38
of your bundle
thank you chair thanks very much for
that
okay um so happy to open it up
to colleagues for questions and first up
is councillor matheson
um yeah could you say a little bit more
about the
um the travel plan situation only the
the reported comment um that you have at
the moment in the report
seems to uh leave us um
not not with it not all tied up yet
yeah of course sorry my apologies i
meant to mention that at the beginning
the the two things on that
if i can we've got an ecology late paper
which was just an update so hopefully
that's that's okay for members and we've
seen that but it it didn't add anything
new
and in terms of the travel plan um yep
been in touch recently with
um county council and confirmed that the
travel plan for 2a has now been agreed
so it was in process at the time we
received that comment
but it has now been agreed um i think
canon consulting are undertaking that
travel plan for phase 2a
thanks you uh councillor mansell
uh thank you chair i've i've got um a
few questions if that's okay um
first question is about uh chimneys
some of the designs of houses have
chimneys can you tell me if they are
what i call false chimneys or chimneys
that are required
because there's an open fire um i
understand that the heating
fuel for this development is gas
and i wonder if there's been any
discussion of using
other main sources of heat
and third thirdly a question about the
very low number of two-bedroom market
houses uh i i think if i've got my
figures correct there are seven
uh two-bedroom market housing um and i
i don't quite follow the the table the
layout of the table we've got on page 60
which is our strategic housing response
i'm not quite sure what the columns mean
um but i've got the impression that
maybe this
is a bit low on two bed market houses so
i just wondered if there was a comment
about that thank you
thanks uh gemma do you want to come in
yeah of course um
yes i do believe the chimneys are false
they are off the majority of the
properties and
are a feature to essentially help
provide a navigation through the site
and this is very similar to what has
been agreed on the previous reserve
matters
and the master plan albeit appreciating
this is not something that we've been
particularly keen on
um and hence the reason they are just
used in those circumstances rather
than across the site as a generic extra
feature um
in terms of gas heating um yes again
it's something we you know we try and
bring up with all
developers through applications again
appreciating that that's something that
we know we
need to work towards alternatives um
but that is the proposal at this time
and and again following on from the
existing reserve matters
um and outline consent the
two bird houses um can you just expand
on that point
in terms of the gas eating yeah so um
it's not something that we can
require essentially at the moment um you
know as i said i appreciate
members are keen on alternatives and
with the climate emergency the
the alternatives are something we try
and explore with developers
but it's not something we can insist
upon at this stage
is that helpful yeah can i also just add
something to if i may just do that
obviously what's in front of us is
reserved matters um
so we are dealing with the appearance
and scale
uh layout um we're unfortunately we're
not dealing with
um the fueling of the properties and i
also just want to add
having dealt with this case of the
master plan of this site
originally the road layout the bit the
main road that goes through with the
roundabout
is in place and one of the reasons that
came forward first
was to enable the gas pipeline to be put
into place
early on so that investment has already
taken place in order to ensure that the
gas
is available throughout all phases of
this proposal to the
ultimate endpoint of 815 houses
when it's finished thank you
thank you back to you gemma
yeah thank you um so in terms of the um
market housing uh again i think the
mix was looked after outline and
although that
this stage has got a different mix
overall
i think uh strategic housing work
content and have have just said
they would like some more one beds on
the next phase um and so it's looking at
that overall
um you know given we've got various
different phases as part of that
thank you
did you want to come back at all
councilman well
you know the answer the questions have
been answered whether i
agree with them or not it's open to
debate so i i don't think i'd say
anything else at the moment
thanks okay counselor ebon
thank you very much chair um thanks um
gemma for your presentation
um could i just ask about the or get a
bit more detail about
keeping that slide you've got up on the
screen at the moment
on the northwest side um
could you just clarify what landscaping
is there and
sort of the relationship between um
could you just confirm again the height
because
very small type in the papers the height
of the fencing
that's alongside the parking spaces and
then
where you've got the red line defining
the site what additional landscaping
will be there and following on from that
um the view into the site across the
fields
from hawley
what i'm just going to do is um we've
got highways here but they're only here
for 10 minutes because they're between
meetings
so if any member has a question on the
highways could i ask you to bring
those up now so we can get answers while
we have highways with us so then we'll
come back to
councillor ebern's point if that's right
does anyone wish to come in on a
highways matter
nothing at this stage okay because we
have sam here for 10 minutes
okay back to you rachel sorry about
teresa trump no that's okay so just uh
the
the question was with regards to the um
what's the height of the fencing by the
parking spaces on that northwest side
and what's the relationship between that
and the landscaping
on the edge of the site and um i can't
get
an appreciation of how deep that
landscape buffer is so if you could just
um explain a bit more on that please
thanks very much yeah of course no
problem
just bear with me while i move
back up a plan
right so the faint orange line
around the very edge is point four meter
high timber knee well so that's the sort
of a
a one up upright with a um beam across
the top down to another upright so it's
very low
essentially does just stop the sort of
cars parking there or people walking in
you still climb over it but it just just
sort of provides that differentiation
between the two
so that runs around through here
um you know rather than the higher level
fencing that the three
three four designs are fencing elsewhere
the pink we can see through the middle
and the blue the second one down and
then the reds
as the brick wall through here so we're
not proposing those
over this side towards the public open
space
and i just think
so i'll just scroll down again this
might be modular quicker
uh there we go
sorry i don't think i included the um
landscape plan on this um
i don't think i can measure off this
plan if you if you could bear with me a
second i can just get that up and
measure off if that would be helpful
um but essentially we do have the
roadway and then the public open space
and then
the pathway coming down before we get to
the edge of the site and hence the
buffer
and i have had confirmation from
landscape that they were content with
the proposed scheme
and that it was in accordance with
master plan but i'm happy to measure
that
if that would be preferable um oh yes i
just wanted an
indication of what because um
looking into the site from from outside
as it were
that that doesn't seem to be much of a
buffer on on the
current um site and i so i just wanted
to get an understanding of what the
buffer should be
on on this one so um but in due course
of the meeting that would be great thank
you jim
yeah no problem thank you
thank you councillor may your next
thanks chair um can you tell me a little
more about the car
um electric charging points is my
reading of the documentation correct
that those charging points will only
provide be provided in
houses with um garages
so we have suggested by condition a
scheme for the electric
vehicle charging so that we can agree
that um
i think that has historically been
something that that we've looked at
because it's easy to provide provide a
plug in a garage
but certainly not going forward that
that has been something we've been
able to provide and essentially making
sure that spaces and extra houses
gives you the opportunity to make sure
that on the outside of house we can
still provide that electricity
point um so that's something that we
would be looking to secure by condition
so you're saying that each dwelling will
have an electric car point
what we asked for a scheme so we'd
literally look at it space by space so
there are some spaces
for houses whereby they are further away
because they're in a small parking area
to the rear
so where it may not be possible in those
cases we might suggest that we agree a
ducting scheme
um but we'll look at that on a
space by space basis as part of the
scheme
so i can't guarantee it would be every
space or every property
but every space where it is possible and
we think that
that we can resolve that as an issue
then yes that's what we would look at
yeah okay just yeah all right thank you
thank you uh casa field
thank you obviously ducting schemes will
be useful
uh just to return for a minute to the
sort of heating issues it's
obviously good to provide uh opportunity
for
retrofitting in the not too distant
future but uh just thinking about
uh initializing levels i wonder if any
comments
what sort of level that's pitched at and
is there any provision for renewables
like
solar panels to be fitted to these
properties
thank you
we haven't had anything specific but
again we have put the
condition on as suggested by the
environmental health sustainability
officer
for a scheme for water energy and
resource efficiency measures
so that we can agree those but they're
not specified at this time
thank you uh councilman
thank you chair yeah electric vehicles
um
that's them dealt with now the the other
one on page 28
um the the construction management plan
submitted is
inadequate um has that been remedied
uh sorry just looking uh okay
so on this one if you can if you look at
this i think probably i haven't made it
clear enough
we then received updated comments from
environmental health so um
while they the initial comments say that
the construction management plan is
inadequate
the comment above thank you for the
opportunity to comment on this i'm
satisfied that the
cems construction environmental
management meets the requirements and is
suitable and need to be complied with
and again that is secured by condition
i see thank you thank you sorry about
that
thank you um can you i've i've got a
question could you just confirm
how many um houses have triple parking
uh and what size houses they are
yeah of course so initially there were
20 houses with triple parking
we during the course of the application
reduced that down to 16 because they're
seeing some
obvious solutions for you know from my
side where we could um
just shuffle the parking around to
prevent that so we're now down to 16
and they are the four bedroom properties
that have the triple parking
so the four bedroom parking have triple
parking with one electric charging point
for three cars that can't
get close to that the third car won't be
able to get close to the house
well we said we would that would be
something we would have to look at
almost on a space by space basis and
consider is
is one charging point in the garage
sufficient for triple parking or does it
also need one on the side
and you know if that's something members
have got strong concerns about and we
wanted to put that on by way of an
informative note and
or indeed as part of the condition that
that's got to
you know where there's triple parking
each space or however many spaces
members feel
should have triple parking then we can
take that away as part of that scheme
okay and could you point out where the
triple so we know triple parking
one of the spaces is in a garage so that
means you have three cars using two car
parking spaces and a garage which often
gets used for other reasons
so where are those cars supposed to park
when they don't actually
have a physical space to park on their
drive so the orange
spaces so we've got two visitor parking
spaces there three around here and a
further three here which
is the small cluster where we've got
triple parking here
so can you just clarify that's for how
many houses so that's six pa
five parking spaces for how many
four-bedroom houses
so there are seven um triple parking
triple parking in that cluster
with five parking spaces for visitors
sorry eight three three three and two
there
okay so okay
and on the other side please uh yep so
so five five in this cluster and there
are
five visitor spaces and then there are
three four in this cluster
with two visitors oh sorry three visitor
spaces and those are all four bedroom
houses
yes okay thank you thank you
i think i've got the plan for cancer
rebound as well if i can um
please just work out how to share that
sorry
um it might be easy to
gemma is it the open space plan you want
for the next side
which isn't ideal but if i just share it
as a screen then
that might work if you bear with me
um in theory that should come up
super that's exactly the one
what you probably can't see is is the
key because i'm conscious that's on the
other side you might have to zoom out a
wee bit john to
show you i come out right
i thought it's not the best trying to
look through eye docs unfortunately it's
not the best
program um and it also is quite slow
uh to load up large plans like this um
so give it a moment it'll update and
then
fill in the gaps down here here we go
unfortunately it's a bit blurred isn't
it um
we need the key do we well i just
thought it might help
with councillor eben's question in terms
of what there is i mean i think
essentially you've got the boundary
landscaping
with the footpath and then we've got the
the areas of um
i think from memory i think they're all
wildflower meadows but um it
is on the key if needs to be i'm sure we
can zoom in on just the key perhaps
john sorry zooming into 50 maybe that
will
no that won't yeah zoom in a bit more
does it is it got it on the tags on
there as well
let's put the mix in so i can just about
see a various mix of
hedgerows and trees and so on all the
way along here i'm would you just want
to talk us through it if we can't
if we can't read it rather than let's
just talk through what's
on there drummer yep so i get my version
yeah i'll just try and see if i can do
anything else with this
um i would say though isn't that whole
area to be transferred
to the council though ultimately that's
part of the 106 agreement
yes it's part of the management
agreement
no this is not helping i'll come back
out of this because it's now
not going very well at all yeah i can't
get the um
key to load up either i'm having
i can get that far out but i can't
actually close in on it which is a
nightmare really isn't it it's really
annoying
okay i'll come out we'll waste a lot of
time otherwise doing that
okay counselor field
sorry that was an old hand i wasn't even
going to comment about the i.t
problems we don't have
thank you council field any other points
that we wish to raise before we move on
uh to the next part of this application
okay thank you um so uh thank you for
that so we now move
um to public speakers now we don't have
a representative
of the parish council or or the town
council and i will
um so i'll now ask the objector
uh all this ask the objective
oh sorry i'm misreading this so uh
robert can you just clarify we
don't actually have an objector or a
supporter is that correct yes apologies
chair that's the type of
we don't have anyone from the parish we
don't have an objective we don't have a
supporter but we do have the app
and so we'll go straight into the
afghanistan agent james bailey and
nicola
sorry nicole lane and you have three
minutes to address the committee please
and uh robert if you can time this for
us thank you
oh uh good morning chad can you hear me
okay yeah
absolutely fine fantastic in advance of
our three minutes i i was just wondering
would it be possible to actually uh
properly introduce ourselves
this morning before we start uh
yes but but i mean you are the agent uh
that's what we need to know i think
fantastic well uh i was going to say
that
uh yes i'm james bailey planning
consultant to taylor wimpy
and i've worked in all of the the
previous phases at northfield view
chilton lee's as it was formerly known
over a number of years
i'm joined this morning by nicole lane
who's the project lead
on the phase but we also have uh
other representatives from taylor wimpey
with us this morning
including mark chapman and andrew wright
and also people from other technical
disciplines
and they're available should members
have any specific questions this morning
and thank you chair that's all i really
wanted to say by way of introduction to
let you know that we do have people
available for
for any specific questions if you're
happy
um should i should i make a start well
i'm afraid i would put that within your
three minutes i mean
you know i introduced you and you just
reintroduced yourself again
so the clock is ticking no problem
uh well here we are again this morning
uh a further phase of development at
taylor wimpy site here
in northfield view in stone market it
continues to be a highly successful site
for taylor wimpey and it's a site that
mid-suffolk council
uh know very uh very well having
featured as an area of housing growth
back in the council's core
strategy it then became a cornerstone of
the stone market area action plan
and following an adopted development
brief that covers the whole of the site
over 800 houses taylor wimpy have been
bringing this site forward over a number
of different and carefully considered
phases
phase one was a detailed application for
215 dwellings
and land for a new primary school that
was consented in 2015
and a full infrastructure application to
cover the whole site
was then granted planning permission in
july of 2017
an outline permission for the remaining
600 dwellings
on the rest of the site followed in july
of 2018
with phase 2a for 175 dwellings being
approved
uh then in november 2018
the scheme before you this morning is a
reserved matters application called
phase 2b
that is seeking planning consent for 100
dwellings it includes 20 affordable
units as per the 20
requirement that was agreed through the
earlier section 106
with both the district and the county
councils important strategic landscaping
and public open space is also with
included within the application
2b has frequently been referred to as a
connecting phase
which links between the housing from
phase 2a to the north
and also phase 2c to the south the
infrastructure is already in place and
this application is essentially filling
in
the housing parcels and open spacing
areas accordingly
as with previous phases taylor wimpy
have gone out of their way to ensure
that the correct engagement has taken
place
following numerous meetings with offices
there have also been detailed
discussions with the town council
and the parish councils of onehouse and
hawley as well there were no comments
from the county highways
a recommendation of approval was
received from the county floods team
and a note of support from the
application
from one house parish council themselves
there were no objections to the
application
from any of the stakeholders following
that level of detail
uh it shows what the the extent that
we've gone to with this
particular application in this
particular phase
northfield view is a strategically
important site for mid-suffolk
it is featured as an identified area for
growth over many years
and it remains part of the emerging
joint local plan
and we believe it's been sensitively
brought fo forward over these different
phases by taylor wimpy
this phase in front of you being no
exception as well this morning
the proposal has been discussed at
length as we've said
and it's been made uh in line with the
adopted development brief
so i was going to end there and say
thank you very much for your for your
time
but just to reiterate there are several
of us available
should you have any questions this
morning
thanks very much okay
uh i've got a question to start with if
i've got no other hands up um can you
just explain why you've kept 16
uh properties with triple parking um
because
they have a very uh poor track record in
mid-suffolk they don't they don't work
in the states we know people don't use
them
so why have you kept so many in
it's a it's a good point uh on there i i
think
uh the key thing is obviously in terms
of size and space
on there we know uh as you quite rightly
say uh chair that
uh over a period of time there are other
uh examples of schemes that uh this has
proven to be a problem
uh i think it's uh it's one that we are
genuinely aware of and gradually
gradually try to reduce this down
uh over the various phases and hopefully
people can see that from phase one
uh into 2a uh and where we are now and
indeed
through for for subsequent phases as
well the difficulty is
uh that these are the sorts of things uh
that uh oh
somebody just made a message on there uh
that
uh that the the house builders need to
need to address when they're they're
looking at their various sort of layouts
uh and schemes as well we have tried to
to reduce the number down uh during the
course of the application we know
that there is a sensitivity around that
uh but equally
uh we we've we've also tried to work
this particular scheme into the the
constraints that's already going on
uh in terms of the the rights of way uh
and the landscaping and although there
are still a number and we accept that on
there in front of you
it's a it's a balance if you like uh
chair
between uh making sure that every other
part uh of the scheming including uh
as i say the open space and the
landscaping and the provision
works as well we've got a uh an
excessive provision
uh of visitor parking uh we we
uh hopefully you you'll acknowledge that
as well uh
that uh that again hasn't been allocated
to specific housing
it could have been uh on there but we
discussed that through
with the case officer and we've ended up
with uh a series of potential
opportunities but
again the the difficulty is uh it's
it's it's very very difficult to sort of
change
human practice uh on there and and so
i just asked a follow-up question then
so you could get rid of the triple
parking if you had
more three-bedroom houses instead of
four-bedroom houses is that correct
i think to be quite honest we're going
to have i've got some
some of our colleagues from uh from
taylor wimpy if uh if if it's one that
you would like me to to introduce on
because i'm
very conscious that this is a it's a an
important topic mark's obviously just uh
appeared on here
as well one of the directors at east
anglia yeah
morning chair morning members so i just
thought i'd join today's meeting because
we we do appreciate there's a
particularly sort of sensitive
issue um back in 2017 james and jack
i sat in front of you for the for the
outline planning commission and many of
you will remember that there was a
viability
um that the uh planning commission was
actually based on
um so so the way that viability being
put together
um was looking at the phase one site
and effectively pro rattering it up um
so so the phase one site has 18
triple stack parking and only 8 visitor
parking
so that was what the viability was was
based on um
appreciating that it that it's an issue
that probably we weren't as aware of
back in
uh 2017 as we are now we've done
whatever we can
to to work these uh out that the housing
mix so
so chair you mentioned there you can
make four beds three to three beds
that that's true the problem is we're
then affecting the housing mix that the
viability was based on
so um importantly uh back
on phase one the 18 of triple stack
parking is accessed off both
private and adoptable roads
so we're now down to 16 um
triple stack parking so 16 properties
uh 35 visitor parking so a massive uh
increase there and well above uh the
suffolk uh
levels for in the parking standards um
and they're all off private roads so
none of these
uh properties have got triple stack uh
parking
off um the adoptable roads
which helps um so so we have worked hard
and your officers do
do work as hard on this point it's it's
very difficult on a site like this
where you know this is a hundred homes
in isolation but it's part of a 600
uh home phase we've obviously got
another 325 to bring to you
in the future and and we can always
undertake to you
that we will never have more than 18 on
this site because that's what we based
our viability
uh on at the time of outline but i can't
say that there won't be
any at all um because then we do get
back into that viability discussion um
where it's you you can't fit the the
amount of housing that obviously pays
for the infrastructure the
the school um that's required for this
scheme and
we obviously know that affordable
housing was negotiated hard here
and and got to a level of 20 so
we we're doing as much as we can within
that constraint
of viability and we really have um gone
a long way
we do really appreciate the issues and
we know that
um particularly in the mid-suffolk area
there's some
some examples um uh where triple stack
parking has caused a lot of issues
um particularly something like cedars
park and and where i'll
just say there is is uh there's another
factor where some of those developments
were brought forward before the current
uh suffolk parking standards making sure
that four beds had at least three spaces
and the likes so some of those have less
than the uh the current parking
standards
um allow we've got those current parking
standards and we're over providing
in visitor parking i personally live on
one of our developments where we have
triple stack parking and we have visitor
parking as we've shown today
and it works fantastically because
on the days where you really need
visitor parking christmas day and
those sorts of things um everybody parks
on the driveway
and the visitors actually use the
visitor parking um so it's a much more
flexible approach
than allocating visitor parking to
individual houses
um because obviously on those quieter
days um
your neighbor can't go and park in your
parking space so we do find that
this approach works and and like say we
can undertake that going forward you
will never see more than 18
which was the agreed at viability um but
we're doing everything we can to reduce
it
thank you for that explanation uh
councilor matheson
thank you perhaps i i could start
while mr chapman is is in front of us so
to speak as well
um i was intending to
ask in our conditions at the end of this
that we we condition a small number of
um homes that are particularly suitable
for people with disabilities
and um what i've got in mind is five
that are to the standard of m42 and two
to the sound of m43
and i just wondered whether you think
you can accommodate that
um within your viability that you've
just been talking about
um it's it certainly comes at a cost but
that's not um wouldn't be my my main
concern
certainly the part m43 um
that's a wheelchair user dwelling um and
that means that
for someone who's not a wheelchair user
it's not a particularly um
comfortable living environment so things
like kitchen worktops are
reduced so that if you're in a
wheelchair you have better access
um all homes that are built now
you know can be adapted into wheelchair
user properties
and that's part of building regulations
what we would call part m
m1 really where light switches
access to the property all those things
allow for
ambient disabled and visitor access um
uh for disabled uh use but but m43
is wheelchair users and like i say you
know we're selling to
obviously there's a housing need um in
general um i don't know
uh what figures you have to in terms of
requiring wheelchair users
but but it's not saying that if you're
selling on the open market
if someone who isn't in a wheelchair
looks to buy that home
it won't be a comfortable living
environment for them
well the um i think that the evidence is
in in the
um ten yearly census and um certainly
that would support you know
the two is this is exactly a hundred
properties i think and um
is it yes hundred and um you know
that's two percent which which would be
which would be reasonably consistent
with the census
um figures so i i just just wanted to
put that point to you shall i continue
to my other point here yeah they're
they're questions yeah yeah they they
are um
yeah in terms of the obviously james
everyone's familiar that the committee
is increasingly not happy with gas
central heating what i'm wondering is
whether
you're prepared to commit to offer
photovoltaic installations to people
buying off plan
so so that you can take advantage of the
fact that that you've got all the
scaffolding and everything already there
um so that there isn't the cost of
retrofitting
um to that extent
so in sure i mean we we can offer
to be honest when we've done it before
we it doesn't really get taken up
um so on the on the point of gas heating
um obviously um it's something that
we're working with provide energy
providers uh on uh with the future uh in
mind now
uh as uh mr peyton g pointed out the
the gas was uh uh infrastructure was put
in early on this development because it
was needed to
to feed the to feed the school um
and uh going forward what the big energy
providers are telling us
is that they will have to use the gap
gas network
um but for other solutions so i know in
the press there's been
hydrogen gas mixes discussed and and
there's areas of the country that's been
tested on
so we know uh there's an electricity
issue
um so they're not gonna be able to
switch every single home to electric
um but they will be using the gas
infrastructure to deliver
new forms of energy um uh to housing now
as a house builder we can't dictate that
it's um
it's a regulated industry the the energy
industry
but we're working very hard with those
partners to make sure that it's
future-proofed
um so so in terms of the
photovoltaics there are some offered uh
there are some on the
um on the development already but
um like i say it's not something we tend
to offer as an optional extra because
we've never been taking up on it
if you ask for us to offer it as an
optional extra then yes we can do that
um but i don't want to tell you that
we'll have a large uptake because i
suspect we won't
so you're prepared to offer it yes yeah
we're prepared to offer it
yeah thank you a minute that thank you
chair
okay cancer eben
thank you chair um and thank you to the
agent and appleton for your being here
today
um my question um was with regards to
advanced
landscaping and particularly as you
might have heard my
question to the officer earlier
on on the current site there's a very
stark boundary between the
um housing and the field
in the reports i have now found the
landscaping report and it's
says it's advanced landscaping can you
confirm that you would actually
put landscaping in before the houses are
you commence building the houses so that
we don't end up with that stark um
boundary um that we've had on the
previous
um uh parts of this um
this overall site um so if you you could
confirm that for me and the timing of
that please thank you very much
yeah so um again at the outline there
was actually a
phasing uh plan agreed for these future
um phases for that for that landscaping
so
um with the reserve matters there's a
landscape master plan that's been
submitted and that will have further
detail added through conditions
um but yes the the plan is to always
install that ahead
and one of the things we'll be looking
to do with the next reserve matters
is actually bring forward some plans um
for open space and and the play areas as
well because obviously we want to
make sure all of that infrastructure
comes forward early so so in short yes
yeah we do need to undertake that
landscaping in advance
any concrete i mean not just before the
these kind of
occupation as it were of the yes yeah
and
and again um uh mr peyton g will uh
probably remember better than me but but
i believe there is a phasing plan for
these future phases
um that actually dictates that that
planting will be done before we
commence the housing now that that
doesn't go all the way up to the
boundary of the housing because you need
construction moving space
but there's a buffer of around 10 or 15
meters
that that has to be planted um uh
early so yes we we do want to take to do
that thank you very much for that thank
you
and just to follow uh on from that chair
if i may uh just to say we we've started
discussions
uh with a group from uh stone market
town council they've approached taylor
wimpy if they can assist with some uh
some tree planting which we we've
started discussions on
uh and equally as marcus said uh going
towards the uh
the final phase uh which has got the
sports
uh and recreation facilities uh i think
that it's been mentioned several times
when we've been out to meet with
the parishes uh about any flood lighting
and any sort of protection so it
the onus is on us uh to get the uh the
the landscaping and the planting in
nice and early so that that has been
made loud and clear thank you
thanks very much thanks so much
councillor field
thank you just take advantage of your
presence if i'm running with a couple of
questions
um one of them really um we're seeing a
pretty dramatic
shift towards home working at the moment
i wondered if um as a nimble company
you're making any
adaptions or moving in that direction at
all to accommodate such
trends the other one is sort of similar
on environmental grounds um
presumably a fabric first type approach
but
are you just sticking to sort of what
the building regulations require or is
there any intention
to improve insulation capabilities
to reduce heating costs and the impact
on the environment
obviously scandinavians have been using
triple glazing for 40 years
i'll be moving in that direction at last
or
you know i'm looking for your comments
on those two yes
so on the homework and yes we're
certainly seeing a shift
um from our purchases towards uh
homeworking and we're now
exploring more and more where people who
would normally buy a two bed will
actually buy a three bed because they'll
use the third bedroom as a
as a study and that goes throughout
throughout the housing range
um so yes we are and and what we're
looking at is
what do our customers expect then in
terms of uh electrical infrastructure in
the house to to do that now
nowadays it doesn't tend to be too much
more than a few sockets because
of wi-fi um and the rest so yes we
certainly um
uh allowing for that um in terms of
energy
um yeah so so yes there's a fabric first
uh
approach always because the best thing
you can do is is stop
energy leaving the walls and windows of
the house
rather than replacing it but
the the new building regulations that
recently were consulted on
that that looks like it's going to be
changing to
rather than registering a development
under
one regulation and building the the
whole development so historically we
would have been able to register
600 homes here under uh 2013 regulations
and build it out
that that's not the case going forward
so you've probably heard about the part
l and f that was consulted on throughout
last year
what will happen is uh as those
regulations get adopted
house builders will need to um
make any house that they haven't started
to those new regulations and that's a
combination of
of increased specification so it could
be
increased wall thicknesses to get even
more insulation but also things like
technology so
air source heat pumps and alike are
more likely to come through um that we
probably increased pv
but that will actually be dealt with
through the building regulations going
forward so
so as we go through this site and those
building regulations actually come into
force um
we will be required to meet those new
regulations
um and my understanding at the moment is
any
uh foundation that goes in after june
2023
will will have to meet those uh those
new regulations
this phase doesn't actually start until
january 2023 because it takes that long
to detail design tender get contractors
uh uh on on board so most of this
phase will actually be under those new
regulations
i presume thank you thank you
hope on the horizon thank you councilman
do you want to come in
thank you chair um uh uh having this
earlier discussion about the um
landscaping
i i've i've looked at the um whatever is
the um
ecological mitigation plan uh and could
somebody explain to me
why the hedgehog friendly fencing is
only in
certain parts of the development uh my
other question is just
purely out of interest about the
the area of the development that you've
called holy church view
can you really see holy church uh from
those houses
uh if we take the the latter one first
if we may
thank you councillor mansell uh i think
that uh that is probably
uh uh a little bit far uh in terms of
the view but uh
nonetheless what has happened is that
something that's historic from
uh from the development brief when that
was uh uh sort of done
many years ago uh and uh john payment g
and councilman matheson and others will
recall
those were one of those uh areas uh that
were looked at indeed when we're looking
at the
at the final phase uh we've been talking
uh
about views towards uh fimbra church and
actually uh you
can't see that one either uh so uh it's
one of those where
perhaps the definition isn't quite right
uh but certainly the alignment and the
way that this is all worked and
orientated
is still spot on uh and again it's one
of those that sort of
evolved uh from uh from being an
identified area in the course strategy
or all the way through a development
brief and actually it's coming
out of the ground now so you're probably
quite right it probably does
uh it does need to be renamed over a
period but yes
uh it's still there uh in terms of the
the
the hedgehog uh holes as it were the
hedgehog highway
um we'd like to think that our uh our
ecologists that have worked with us on
various phases throughout this
have got that right um was there a
concern that perhaps there wasn't enough
uh
highways should we say for the hedgehogs
through through the development
it was that the concern well well i just
i i i've never seen a map showing them
before so so thank you for putting the
detail on the map maybe i just haven't
looked at them but
i was just intrigued as to why okay i
can understand the big
background the edges near the green
space but there's sort of one
high hedgehog highway that does head
towards the
the central spine road on one side but
there's nothing like that on the other
i mean obviously there is a reason for
this and i was just interested so
uh you don't need to to answer it but
you've obviously thought about it your
ecologist has decided that those are the
ones
that are needed to be done i just i'd
always assume that maybe they all had
little
hedgehog holes in um i didn't realize it
was only a specified view
well i i think that's excellent because
i'm going to look to mark and say
did we bring our hedgehog highway
specialists with us tonight i know the
answer to that question
i think the point of this is that this
is one of those where
there is an evolution i think it's very
important that some of these
enhancements are done
these are the sort of plans that people
have been requiring over a number of
years so actually we've got one in front
of us which we can look at
uh yes uh i i think it's quite helpful
uh to to have those points
we'll certainly feed them back uh on
there and indeed perhaps next time when
we do come we'll bring our specialists
along but
thank you for raising that and i'm
grateful you've noted it as well i think
it's the first at the planning committee
okay uh councillor matheson
yes chip sorry sorry to have to come
back to this but mr chapman did did say
that all the
properties would be um wheelchair
adaptable
um but no i think that category one and
i've got the um
part m up in front of me now
category one are visitable dwellings
category two
are the adaptable dwellings and if he
was going to provide
all uh all properties to be
up to to stand to two that would be
great but
i think another developer recently um
a couple of committees ago did did say
that they were going to do
everything to m41 which was good
but that's not m42 and it's not
adaptable
so i i think we need to be clear what we
are
getting there please yeah
no apologies if i said that what i meant
was every property will be m41
um as you say m42 is adaptable so that
when we say adaptable we're talking
about major
adaptations so we're talking about being
able to take out a wall between
um a bedroom and a bathroom so that you
can put a hoist in
to hoist from from a bed to a bath um
no we're not we're not undertaking to do
uh to do that
um it's it's the m4 one where it's
accessible to visitors to guests like
say things like um
the access into the property um allows
for ambient disabled so no large steps
um there's always a route into the
property where you
if you are sort of ambient disabled
you're able to get in and things like
the electrics are a height where you can
use them
um but it's still designed around um
fully uh abled uh body people
yeah thank thank you yes um i i think
you've got the point the evidence is
there
so we'll come back to that later on
thank you uh counselor
did you want to come back or we're going
to move on
thank you okay all right if you take
okay well thank you very much for
joining us and thank you for answering
all those questions
thank you very much okay um so we have
two ward members counselor barry
humphries and councillor oliver
ammoroson and neither are here today and
neither have commented or written
in or added any comments so um
we can't take questions for the ward
members so therefore we go straight into
debate so i'd now like to open up
for debate um over to members to discuss
and reach conclusion on all the
information that's been put before us
today
counselor mueller your hand's going up
thank you chair i've listened with
interest to
to what we've heard so far but i still
have a very big concern about the number
of
triple parking spaces on this
development which is 16 properties 16
percent of the actual development
and i might say like a record that's got
stuck in its groove but i see
this on a daily basis where the number
of cars per house sold seems to increase
people do not use their garages and we
see the cars parked on the pavement or
grass verges
um so um generally i like the
development i like the ecology
aspects of it but i still have deep
concerns about the triple parking and i
know in the past this committee has
deferred applications
where triple parking has been an issue
and the developers come back with an
alternative plan
but i listen with interest what other
colleagues have to say thank you chair
we don't have any other hands up so i'm
happy to comment and
with me um i do have a real be in my
bonnet as well about triple parking
because i've been to estates where
it just doesn't work but i i do actually
think i've got to give credit to taylor
wimpey that they
they have thought this through uh and
they're not just coming in here and
saying that's the way it
is uh the visitor parking bays are
way in excess of what we'd normally
expect so i think
my instinct is that does cover it and
will help
um so while in the past i've been uh
far very vociferous on my view on this i
think the fact they've put in so many
extra visitor parking way above the
recommended amount
probably will help it and and pull it
out and make it acceptable
um it's marginal but for me um i
i feel that that that particular issue
um
is as close to being addressed as we're
likely to get um
but see what others have to say i've got
counselor pass more next
uh thank you very much um matthew good
morning everybody
um yes i've listened to this debate with
the
great interest action i'm really uh
pleased to uh
have a good grasp and understanding of
all the uh recommendations for reserve
matters and the way that the uh
the the developer is looking at the
concerns raised i do
absolutely share your concerns about
triple parking
and uh i do like the effort that have
been made i absolutely agree with you
chairman
i just wonder at this stage i would
perhaps
not perhaps i will propose um approval
of these reserve matters
but wonder if we could put a caveat and
ask um taylor wimpy and the developers
just to reconsider that again with the
offices under a delegated authority
if there are any further improvements
even at this late stage it could be
undertaken
otherwise um chairman i'm happy to
propose um granting permission for these
reserve matters
for this development thank you thanks
very much
cancer passport council manchester
united sorry chairman if i may
come in was that a proposal and was that
what
was that proposal to grant reserve
matters as recommended
or was it a proposal to delegate no
propose to grant
um as proposed but to delegate officers
to
have further discussions around the
triple parking okay
um my concern with that is how
it doesn't give us a resolution to
actually make a change
so it needs to sorry ian if you'd like
to come in on that please if you
would like to i think i agree what
you're about to say john carry on
okay so um if you're delegating to
offices
to see if there's an improvement and
then to incorporate that improvement
and then issue the approval that's fine
or
we're granting uh as the recommendation
before us right now it needs to be one
or the other i can't
um seek an improvement because i won't
be able to integrate it without it being
one
type of resolution or the other does
that make sense cancer possible back to
you
well it does it does sort of make sense
i'm just trying to be pragmatic to
to help move this forward so
if i was to say well i'll recommend
approval as it stands
then there would be no further debate
discussion
on the triple parking issue would that
be correct
so how would you like me to phrase it if
we wanted the okay let me let me
make a suggestion could we could we
could i just throw something in the mix
could we ask
that that the exploration isn't around
the triple parking because that's not
going to change
it's around having a few more visitor
parking spaces
which actually makes it okay which is
the only way we can really balance out
you say
on the viability grounds they're not
going to change the four bedrooms but we
might know to squeak in another three or
four visitor parking bays which will
just help the matter would you be happy
with that tim
i would be very happy with that
personally so you look so
you're looking to delegate to offices to
um
secure further visitor parking where
practically
possible and uh then continue to approve
the development as set out in the papers
thank you the actual the decision to
grant
the reserve matters is actually being
delegated to officers as is quite it's
quite common to say
when we've got a section 106 on an
outline or any application
delegated authority to the officers when
the 10106 has been done this is just a
slightly
a varied version of that thank you yeah
okay thank you thank you
councillor uh thank you um
i am i have a be in my bonnet about
false chimneys uh someone else had been
a
bonnet about triple parking um and i and
i
whilst i i realized that this is a
continuation of the previous phases of
the children fields development
and in a way it's a bit of a shame
because i feel that it's a bit sort of
stuck in a rut because of those
previous um uh permissions and and uh
applications that went before this that
have
if you like made sure that this
development uh has has to have gas
heating
uh has to be like what's gone before and
just because the previous phases have
got a load of false chimneys does that
really mean that we have to carry on
all the way through the development
despite the fact that fashions and
and things change um uh and clearly
things are
things have changed um um so in some
respects
i think that's a pity that that we we're
sort of stuck with
what went before us on the issue of the
parking
um having listened to the discussion
that's just been gone on
i'm not sure i am in favor of of uh
trying to find more visited parking
spaces because i think it's which comes
first
chicken or the egg if you provide more
parking spaces
you'll end up filling them with cars um
so um
and as somebody who lives in a village
where there is a large tail of wimpy
development
where i think they've got sort of
similar arrangement of these parking
bays next to the
uh green open space with a little post
and rail fence around them
um and and i think it it looks like it
it works reasonably well uh and i think
taylor wimpy
have thought about it and i would be
reluctant to
increase the number of parking spaces i
would be more
happy if we could get rid of some false
chimneys and put other things that are
featured
on on houses uh but i i suspect i'm
um hitting my head against a brick wall
about that but
um i i do i mean triple parking is
is an issue but i think taylor wimpy
have thought about it
i think what we've got here is
acceptable and i would rather we didn't
look for more parking spaces on this
site
okay well there may be that they can't
find them um
but anyway okay we'll keep going on um
counselor eben
um thank you very much chair um i am
my concern about this site is that is
the future proofing effectively i mean i
know you can't
permanently future proof but it feels
that we
um the application we've got today is as
at
as at what needs to be done today not
what could be done
um when the construction starts and when
these
these properties are lived in
and that um we really need to be
thinking
more about you know how they are powered
um the the water conservation much
further beyond
um potentially what what's here today
and i appreciate
the developer only needs to do what is
in current building regs
um but i i would like to have seen a
little bit more about
um moving this forward um
you know as as a lot of the public want
to see in terms of you know energy
consumption
and um you know incorporating pv
into the design on the roofs you know
that that would have been
a step forward um so
and with regards to i don't want
anything about parking particularly my
concern
is more the fact that we should be
encouraging more people to walk and
cycle
and the fact that the cycle storage is
effectively the shed down the bottom of
the garden
which frankly will be filled up with um
garden furniture and toys and
barbecues and so on and not cycles and
that we've
you know need to think more carefully
about
having secure cycle storage at these
properties um
that's easily accessible so that people
are encouraged to to cycle and not not
just drive
but um i appreciate this is a
continuation of the um of 2a as it were
and so you know there's this
possibly a lot of these discussions were
done you know and i was involved in them
way back
when um how many years ago eight nine
years ago i think
um so i'm i would just like to have seen
the developer come forward and be a
little bit more forward thinking
um on this particular site thank you
very much chair thanks
thank you councillor mayor
thanks chair um i think yeah
i've been impressed with the
presentation and thank the
um agent and developer i feel as though
i do
have a good understanding of um how this
development is going to
move forward parking i'm not overly
concerned about the triple parking
because there are um quite a number of
visitors parking spaces
and i i can see how you know
integrating those two together would be
a quite a flexible approach so
i'm not too worried about that um
chimneys
i was interested to hear that the the
officer spoke about the chimneys being
necessary to aid navigation through the
site
um i found that rather strange um i
wonder what other tracking skills we're
going to need to move through the site
um probably unnecessary but i'm
not going to die in a ditch over
chimneys i do worry about the electronic
charging as well
i know it's been conditioned but
if when the um
the officer talks to the developer about
where we can put in charging points
houses are left without charging points
then that has a direct impact on the
layout to me if that were to happen then
the layout
is inappropriate so i in future
um decision making
i i would be very keen to see an
electron
electronic charging point plan presented
um when we do talk about layout but all
in all i think this is a
a good
it's a it's a it's a good layout it it
works well for me and i'm happy to
second
uh councillor passmore's um
recommendation
thank you thanks very much uh councilman
thank you i i yeah i have to explore
uh councillor burns theme unfortunately
about looking to the future more um an
interesting point actually first of all
on the on the false
chimneys i i was listening to
uh um a architect designer who
um has been building zero and zero
emission houses for it for a decade or
so
and um when they're retro fitting
they they now they now actually use the
existing chimneys
for heat recovery to install heat
recovery
so it may be that instead of not putting
false chimneys on or not
we should be actually putting real real
chimneys in in order to facilitate that
in the future
and more broadly the um
you know what is worrying me now more
and more is that we're going to finish
up
trying to persuade people to retrofit
these houses
to to to actually bring them in line
with with
our 2030 um ambitions for
zero net zero emissions of co2
and the government's um further further
ahead
similar um and really
retrofitting is so much more expensive
than actually getting the things
properly future-proofed at the right
time
and um you know i think the other
related point to all of that
is is the one about flood um
flood risk the the land to the south
from here
um goes down into the valley of the
river
rat and the flooding
that has got very bad in the last two
winters down there
um and um
although we're told well know that this
is the development we will make matters
better because we will hold the water
and so on and so on
the reality unfortunately is more
flooding and more water
and more trouble now i don't think i
ever found out where the
where the um the balancing ponds for
this development
would drain into but
um i i i'm just you know starting to ask
i think i did ask
um the the planning officer um
about the the the paving paving or
tarmac point which is is in the um is in
in the paper somewhere taylor wimpy
please start thinking about things like
absorbent
paving because we we're going to need
those things
and i'll be returning to the um
the flooding theme with with the chair
at a later stage
in another meeting thank you
okay um i think that's uh
we've got some old hands uh a cancer
field
i think yours is a new one over to you
yes just for once it's a new one
um
i find the uh i was quite convinced by
the taylor
wimpy argument on parking and i don't
honestly believe that constraining space
makes the cars go away
it just makes people's life a misery
at the moment perhaps sometime we will
move
away from cars and it won't be a problem
anymore but
at the moment it is i have to say i'm
somewhat more concerned perhaps by the
issues of the environment that heat loss
from housing we are moving at a fairly
glacial
pace towards new building regulations
it would be good to see developers
moving
willingly and rapidly towards those
standards
um but perhaps that's asking too much
and we clearly don't have
a legal basis for making such demands
so reluctantly one might drop them
i i think the endless discussion of
hydrogen
at the moment is hydrogen might believe
um
perhaps people don't understand what the
how low the sort of ignition energy for
our hydrogen is and the
um hazards in that area
so it's a nice idea but it really is
just to
fend us off maybe sometime
there will be a utopia on its way
i think charging is a is a bigger issue
clearly houses won't have three cars
all charging up at the moment some may
most won't
but we are moving firmly in that
direction and on quite a tight time
scale
i certainly personally will be at the
view that
we should make sure that the the basic
house
wiring structure should be able to
support multiple charges
and that a smaller number perhaps be
provided
right now but if you're going to try and
put in
three seven kilowatts or three 22
kilowatt charges in the future
you're going to have to make sure the
house can support that level of
electricity usage so i think there is an
issue there are
issues there again i really don't know
how we as a committee can legally
support those sort of forward-looking
and
somewhat wise moves so currently i think
i will be
supporting this application with some
concern that as usual
there are opportunities which are not
particularly expensive which are being
missed
thank you thanks
very much okay well um i'll just be the
last one to speak i guess so yes i'm
also going to support this application
um i
i do credit taylor wimpy with having
thought about the triple parking
um if there are a couple more business
spaces i don't see that as a negative
because
i'm afraid if someone wants to drive
there they will drive there whether
there is or isn't a parking space
and if there isn't they'll just park on
the grass so if if there are
even just two more spaces that is found
across the whole estate
i see that as not a negative um i can
see why councillor mansoor doesn't see
it as a positive but i think it's better
than having the grass optional
or people parking up on a pavement or on
the side um
of the road um so i will support it um
i think you know on the electric
charging points
i think officers have heard very clearly
that we really do think that it would
not be acceptable
that not every house clearly has easy
access to
uh electric charging because that is the
only way forward
okay so i think everyone's spoken that's
wanted to speak
it's been proposed by councillor pasmore
and seconded by councillor mayor
um can i just uh sorry john
were you trying to come back in again
yeah i just wondered
if could we perhaps now just have a
little discussion about the
the conditions um i mean i can see no
reason to vote against this
but on the other hand yes that's what we
that's what we do we now ask the
uh officer just to run through exactly
what we're being asked to decide
uh so i can ask the chief planning
officer just to read out the proposals
on what's being asked before we go to a
vote
thank you chair i think i realize i'm
awesome ask for some other conditions
chair or
refine them yeah we could do that once
we know what we're being asked to decide
first
councilman then we'll come back to
councillor passmore and to councillor
mayor and it's up to them as they've
proposed and seconded
so if i may could i could i read out
what i've written would that be helpful
uh yeah we if you read that essentially
we've not changed anything other than
the
uh version of delegation so if you want
to come
back with that please thank you um so i
have
added so be approved that the
application be approved as detailed in
the office of recommendation with the
added
delegation to the chief planning officer
to secure further visitor parking where
practically possible
and the conditions are as set out on
page 37
of your papers 58 also 37
yeah they're onto your mind my my
apologies um
the also it does for clarity
um include what was actually conditioned
to outline
uh at the end just to remind members
that the obviously a number of issues
are already covered by the outline
permission
yeah and this is obviously reserved
matters thank you
thank you okay counselor are you happy
with that
uh yes thank you everything that's right
councillor mayor
yes thank you thank you uh councillor
matheson
thank you um yes just refining
a little landscape implementation
condition
that some of that would be advanced
lands planting before commencement
and also that the um the mix of
the mix of grasses for biodiversity
which which is mentioned
and that that would be included in that
condition please
and also that the just one second
i think we're covering old ground i
thought we we'd already heard from
taylor wimpey that they were going to be
rolling out the planting
as as you've just said so we've all
that's already been discussed
yeah it is well it should be a condition
if it's going to be
if it's you know going to be done um
yeah the the grass grass mix is on page
30. um specifically
and um the
lighting to be wildlife friendly
lighting i think was the other one that
i noticed
and also that the the energy and
resource efficiency
to be agreed um before commencement
can i just ask gemma just to run through
please are those already in the
conditions that
the points that council matters made so
um the landscape implementation
is as the plans proposed and i think
that includes the phasing but certainly
we can make sure that that is
absolutely detailed in that um as far as
the ecological points
they i think came from the first
comments from the um
ecology ecologist those have been um
agreed so for example the street
lighting scheme that has been confirmed
as being appropriate for biodiversity
so that would be implemented as approved
um
have i covered everything i feel like
i've missed something but
a grassroots commencement energy and
resource efficiency before commencement
agreed
that's what's asked for by the officer
yep so if that's what's proposed by
the sustainability officer that's what
we would do yeah well that's all very
satisfactory thank you chair
thank you uh councillor field
yes just uh i was struggling with the
superfast broadband
um i see that's actually an outline
uh county scrutiny were informed by
openreach i think that they provide
fiber to the premises for free
if it's more than 20 houses in the
development
i was wondering whether we could
encourage the move in that
uh somewhat i think that's already
imposed in the i think that's already in
the outline but we'll double check
gemma is the outline says super fast
that's sort of fine for five years ago
unfortunately because the outline was
five years ago
it's what we are stuck with in respect
of the
outlying considerations in terms of
reserve matters appearance landscaping
we can't really get
much further into changing the
definition of broadband or what should
be
applied to this site uh i would only
imagine though that
hopefully uh developers in order to make
their houses marketable would be keeping
up with the times in what's required in
this
virtual world that we're all in at the
moment thank you thank you for that
councilman
uh thank you um can't we have some
reassurance that these
extra parking places that everyone else
seems to want
in this development are not going to eat
into the public open space
or the landscaping or any of the
ecological mitigation
because i'm a bit worried that if you're
asking them to cram some more car
parking in
they'll eat into the green space so can
we can we make sure it's not going to do
that
and if if they really can't find any
more space without
eating into the green space then they
shouldn't be doing it
can i give you reassurance and i can
give you reassurance on two basis
firstly a lot of the public open space
area
is to be transferred to the council as
public
open space and that was part of the
outline
106 agreement i think ultimately looking
at the plan
there might be the one or two spaces
possible but there's not going to be
much more beyond that
without intruding into the public open
space or without
intruding into the wildlife measures so
uh i think i'm quite happy to give you
that reassurance
thank you very much thank you okay so on
that basis
uh we're now going to go to the vote
uh so can i ask the government's officer
can we conduct an electronic vote please
thank you chair if members could please
go to the modern.gov
app and click and go to today's agenda
and click the plus sign in the top right
hand corner
there you'll get the subsection for
attendance and voting if you could
please go on that and go to the voting
tab
the vote is now in progress in the light
blue color
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and i can confirm that that is
eight votes for
and is unanimous thank you very much
okay
uh thank you very much for that um and
uh thank you
taylor wimpy for joining us today um
what i propose to do is to take a break
now
and to start again at 11 15 so in 12
minutes
um when we'll pick up the next
application so we'll take a 12 minute
break
thank you
thanks very much everyone and welcome
back to uh the development
control committee of mid software
district council so we're now moved to
uh the second application before us
today
gender item 7b in walsh from the willows
three dc2100113 now like to hand over to
avril goody the case officer
to present hello there sorry german if i
may interrupt i apologize um
just before we go uh to the case officer
um there's just a couple of things i
wanted to say
before uh in respect of this application
but also the following
uh two applications so
in may uh last year 2020 the coronavirus
act
2020 was was put into place and it
included
a wide range of powers and provisions uh
and it was followed by a number of uh
regulations that uh fitted into it as
well
um this included the power for local
authorities to hold
virtual meetings as we are doing right
now but many of these provisions
were time limited and that includes
actually the virtual meeting we are
having
which expires late may um these
provisions
include time limited permitted
development rights
allowing development to go forward
without needing planning permission
and the right for the development
includes but was not limited to
the change of use of existing buildings
new modular buildings
and also included a range of
elements such as new hospitals health
facilities testing centers
you can imagine why obviously but it
also included additional
residential accommodation so the
applications that we've got
um were the consequence of those
regulations and uh because they were
time limited
the time is expiring and therefore they
are now for
before us as formal planning
applications
uh to be made because obviously if they
do not rectify
the time limit issue then they would
have to be reverted back to
what they were before so
um that that's just really just to put
into context um
the three applications that are before
members today uh that aval is going to
present
um you know the council engaged as the
council uh these powers
uh to provide accommodation and uh we
need to consider the applications
formally as planning applications on
their merits i just wanted to clarify
that before we started thank you
okay thanks very much
answer field you've got a question on
that point yes this can
make it clear one of the applications
clearly states that the work
has been carried out and we're sort of
retrospectively approving work that has
been done
the other two are considerably less
clear
um you know that as to whether the
actual building workers
has physically been completed or not
could we have some clarity around that
yes um so the case officer will go
through each one uh individually and
explain
the current position of works um but
there was
because it was under permitted
development in terms of change of use
or indeed physical work so in some cases
they've been extended
um that was didn't require planning
permission at that time
but it does need it now because that
provision uh through the corona
virus uh act is uh running out in terms
of the time
constraints within the act itself so
essentially they are retrospective
applications um
but in a way they're not because
retrospective implies someone stopping
something wrong but they haven't
done anything wrong here it's just
they've worked with the provisions
available at the time
i understand all that i
my only one has started as my
understanding but we'll go through each
one individually and can ask that
question
thank you thank you okay over to the
case officer
thank you chairman thank you john so
just for a quick summary on this one
this one they haven't
commenced the change of use um just
because
the um it wasn't deemed the immediate
need for this residential unit at the
time
um so they decided to go down the
planning permission route
so the application seeks full planning
permission for the change of use of the
common room to a general needs dwelling
the erection of a single story rear
extension and other external alterations
to the building
so the application is to be determined
by committee as mid-suffolk district
council
are the applicant and own the land
and this is an aerial image so the
application site is within the village
of
badwell ash for some context this is
huntston
road i presume you can see my cursor
yeah okay this is huntsman road
connecting south towards
dolantoft and elmswell and this is the
street connecting north
towards baltimore willows rich road
runs east up towards long furlough and
the application site is a lot
situated along richer close which is
accessed off richer
road the application site comprises
of a terrorist of seven single-story
dwellings
six of which are existing residential
units and the seventh
central one is the common room the site
is surrounded by residential properties
several of which also council-owned and
on council-owned land
so as john briefly mentioned the common
room
was previously used as a focal point for
the residents when the units
formed part of the sheltered housing
scheme
but they have since become de-sheltered
and are now general needs
and therefore the common room has fallen
into disuse and is no longer required
so the red line dictates the application
site which is the central building for
the common room
and on the right hand plan you can see
the dark grey area
illustrates the extent of the proposed
single story extension
in terms of constraints so as previously
mentioned the application site is on
council-owned land
and is also then the built up area
boundary of badwell ash
so here the top image shows the existing
rear elevation
with the existing single story element
to be
demolished with the flat roof here and
then below is the view of these from
the side
and this is the front elevation it's the
building here with the chimney
you have the existing single access door
to the front and the double access door
which is for access to the boiler room
and this is the existing floor plan so
it shows the common room to the rear of
the building
and the boiler room to the front the
unit also has a kitchen and a toilet
so as i mentioned the existing flat roof
is to be demolished and this is depicted
in the purple outline
on the plans you see here
the proposed extension would have a
pitched roof with a ridge height
to match the existing and the materials
would be concrete pan tiles
and facing brickwork to match the
existing building
the alterations to the front elevation
include the removal of these double
doors
and bricking up with bricks to match
and replacement with a window and also
the vent
to the right of there is replaced with a
window
so this shows the extension which would
protrude
from the rear elevation by 3.8 meters
and it would measure the length of the
building which is
6.7 meters so the change of use would
create a
two-bedroom general needs unit with a
living room
kitchen and bathroom
so just for some context here's some
photos at the forefront of this photo is
the common room building
you can see this this is a single access
door and the double doors for the boiler
room with
the neighboring general needs units um
to the rear of the photo
and this is just another um close-up of
the front elevation
showing what's going to this is going to
be bricked up with the window and this
is the vent to be replaced with a window
and the rear elevation this is the
single story flat roof
element to be demolished
and this just gives a bit of a wider
view of the rear of the terraces showing
the
flat roof element to be demolished
and just for the parking provision for
the site so it currently benefits from
this lay-by which runs along the
majority of
which are close there's also a small
parking area
to the west and several of the
properties have
driveways as well so the the proposal
doesn't include any
parking additional parking as it's
considered that the
existing parking provision is sufficient
to provide one to two parking spaces
per dwelling for the general needs units
at richard close
and then this is just a on the ground
photo of that parking area showing some
cars
parked there so
in summary the application seeks to make
good alternative use of the common room
which is currently
disused the the conversion would provide
a two
bedroom general needs unit to help meet
local housing needs
the extension is small in scale and the
materials would match the existing
the proposal would not alter the
existing parking arrangements which are
considered sufficient to serve the site
the officer recommendation is therefore
for approval subject to the standard
time frame and approved plans condition
thank you
thanks very much for that and do we have
any questions counselor matheson first
yep presumably there's some reason why
the boiler room is
the boiler is no longer needed um but
also i wonder
if we're going to take the opportunity
to put um pv panels on because curiously
this this roof had not got them on where
the other
bungalows have
yeah i mean it's not formed part of this
proposal um
i mean the applicant is with us today so
whether he might touch on
whether that is proposed kind of further
down the line
and ask them we can ask them when they
come good
thank you councillor muller thank you
chair i must admit i was going to ask
exactly the same question as councillor
matheson so no further questions
thank you councillor field
similar but uh not quite the same um
the the plan says phase one development
sort of implies there might be a phase
two what are we not learning
um the other point is that uh
you know the boiler room just evaporates
um
presumably it's not there for
entertainment what's it replaced by
gas boilers in all the other buildings
or uh
do they just freeze or you know just
what what is
what is happening in that area please um
and one question perhaps it's got a
front extension none of the other
properties have
is that because they're all sort of one
bedroom and this is two-bedroom
i didn't quite understand thank you
thank you
yes i think the reference to phasing um
isn't really relevant
at this stage at one point it was just
showing i think that one
it was just going to be one bedroom to
start with and then when the works the
boiler room commenced that would then be
converted to a second bedroom
i believe i will let the applicant
confirm for definite but i believe the
boiler room
they're being replaced with air source
heat pumps but i don't want to give that
as a definite answer it's probably
something worth nasty application
yeah i mean in terms of the extension
that is purely
a rear single story rear extension to
facilitate
kind of making it that habitable space
for a residential unit
so the other units aren't that have a
habitable space isn't my interpretation
i believe the other units are one
bedroom and this is
to provide two bedrooms thank you
okay thank you very much no other
questions so we'll move on
so um we don't have a representative of
the parish council or an objector or a
supporter
but we do have the applicant glenn allen
so over to you and you have three
minutes to address the committee please
hello my name is glenn allen i'm a
building surveyor for
mid-suffolk district council could you
turn your camera on please
oh sure start the clock don't worry
thank you hello my name is glenn allen
i'm a building surveyor for mid-suffolk
district council
the uh explanation that avril gave at
the beginning pretty much covers
exactly what the building has been or is
intended to be converted for
there was a requirement seen at the
beginning of the covert
epidemic and it was a requirement that
from government that the council's
provided
emergency accommodation i believe as
it's turned out the
epidemic hasn't been anywhere near as
serious as perhaps was considered to be
the very worst case scenario
so there were three properties uh in a
phase one of this
project which were converted last summer
and then there was a second
phase which this forms one of those
addresses
that was going to be developed again
under permitted development and just
pushed through if you like but but
the the management team for the council
decided
that these phases would be done more
traditionally by
getting applications in for planning for
building regulations and then going out
to tend to the work in the usual way
to answer some of the questions that
were asked earlier on
the original intention because this was
going to be done under permitted
development and done very quickly
is that the boiler room needed to stay
in place because that provides heat
and hot water for some of the other
buildings
in the terrace basically because the
property was standalone sheltered at one
point
uh all of the infrastructure in there
still exists for that and they don't
up bar one property they don't have
individual heating
and hot water sources
the the change of uh of
the change of direction by the
management to do this more traditionally
then meant that there wasn't the need to
maintain
the boiler room and whilst creating a
habitable space
and in actual fact what we did is we
then combine combined
the two phases because it's going to be
more cost effective to do that
and also because there is now an ability
to put
individual heating and hot water sources
into the other bungalows
so what will effectively happen is this
development will allow
all of those units which are now general
needs housing
to all be standalone units with their
own heating and hot water source
whilst developing the central underused
or
no longer used space the reason that
that was made two-bedroom is because
because of the layout of the existing
building and the original intention to
have to maintain the boiler room
there needed to be an extension on the
back to get up to
minimum room areas obviously with that
change in tax slightly
that has allowed us to actually make
that a slightly more significant
building
in that is now two-bedroom and can
accommodate potentially four people
so what's actually turned out to be a
scheme that was designed
initially about a year ago has actually
developed into what we have now
okay thank you very much so your time is
up so thank you thank you
okay questions counselor mansell
uh thank you chair um thank you for your
explanation about the boiler run because
i too was going to ask exactly the same
question as
councillor matheson and councillor field
uh i'll took my hand down then
but but can you perhaps um uh
mention the fact that about the solar
the pv panels
um the other dwellings in that terrace
all appear to have pv panels
when you look at the aerial photograph
is there any plan to put pv
on this one whilst you're doing the rest
of the building work
currently there isn't the the reason
behind
that is the the benefit for those pv
panels going up there is purely for the
residents so
it's a cost to the council but they
benefit from the electricity saving the
council do not
benefit in any way
what we basically have to do is we
finance putting those on and we have to
finance the maintenance of those but we
don't get any cash payback
therefore when i mean when they were
originally put up
there was uh this feed-in tariff and we
did have some kind of benefit from it
that has disappeared now
and my understanding from my mechanic
and electrical colleagues is that we no
longer put those up because
we incur cost but we gain nothing from
it
well i think that's a debatable point so
i'll leave that for later thank you
thank you uh councillor field
yes we might assume that removing for
fuel
poverty is a gain to the community but
there you go the real question is you
didn't
expand on the heating means in the other
dwellings is it air source heat pumps
ground floor seat pumps
uh or gas boilers and is the
insulation of those buildings up to
either of the sustainable
possibilities
excuse me the new building will be uh
compliant with building regulation
requirements
the heating systems for the other
buildings there's no gas in the area so
they're all going to be air source heat
pump systems
the one of the buildings already
benefits from air source heat pump
uh so what will happen is all seven of
them will have individual systems
thank you that sounds good will you
enhance the insulation to match
their new heating means
at the moment there is no proposal to do
any works on the other properties this
is just the development of
the old common room and the provision
of new heating systems for those
individual units
so that's all that's before us today
john
okay thank you any other questions
nope okay so uh thank you for that um
so we now move over to the ward member
councillor mayor would you like
over to you thank you chair
um i have very little to say other than
to um
just reiterate that the parish council
didn't wish to make any comment
um on a personal basis it
i think it's disappointing if this
project goes forward and the people
living there
are um somewhat discriminated by not
having pv panels i
think they probably question why and um
would definitely benefit from their
installation but
i'll leave that for the committee to
discuss so no comment thank you
thank you very much um you have a
question for the ward member council
muller
councillor miller you've put your hand
up do you have a question for the ward
member
sorry chair i'm trying to get rid of it
okay
yeah sorry no problem okay any
any questions for the ward member nope
okay thank you very much so now over to
us to discuss debate
uh and reach a conclusion on this
application
thank you councillor muller then
councillor mansell
yes apologies for the previous hand that
chair uh yes
um i do actually um really like this
proposal but like uh colleagues i am
disappointed that the residents that
will move into this property once it's
converted
if we grant planning permission uh won't
benefit from from the
solar panels but that's aside um i'd be
happy to move approval
chair thank you thank you
councillor mansell thank you um
yeah i uh i wholeheartedly um agree with
the sentiment of of converting uh uh
what is currently being an unused space
into a habitable dwelling
but i think it is very very
short-sighted
of the applicant and when we talk about
the applicant we're actually talking
about us as a council
and i think that is an extremely
disappointing response
that oh we don't get any financial
benefits so we're not going to bother
putting solar panels on the roof
um as has been said by by councillor
field
um you know getting people out of fuel
poverty
making sure people have enough money to
pay their bill so that they are not
um defaulting on the rent surely that is
a benefit and i
and i think it is a crying shame that we
are not
deciding to put panels on the roof at
the same time
as doing the rest of the building work
because surely that is a more efficient
way of doing it
so i don't know if that can be
presumably we can't add solar panels now
because this is what we've got
um but it seems churlish that we're all
gonna refuse this just because we want
solar panels on the roof and i really
don't know
what um what can be done about it
because we don't want to refuse it
because
on the basis of it it's a good thing um
but it just seems that it's a really
really really short story i think
what we could do is we could put a um
informative note
uh that we wish to see we think it uh
panel should be uh put it on the uh
on the accommodation maybe that's a
possible way or we can condition
the or we could condition that we want
uh pv
um the panels put on the roof it's up to
us we can do one or the other i mean
the difficulty with conditioning is is
um i guess
uh i mean it's not sheltered housing so
i guess it depends who goes into the
housing because obviously it would be
funding that goes to them
so we'd be paying for the panels and the
funding doesn't come to us it goes to
whoever
is renting the property yeah yeah yeah i
realize that but but if
if that is a proposition then if we add
the condition
that we expect to see pv panels put on
the roof
to a condition uh then i might be
willing to second the
proposal can i just ask the case officer
because i mean i just want to get into
the just just so we have clear i mean if
we do that does that mean the rent will
go up because there's a
there's an increased cost in running
that because there's been a you know
how's that going to actually
impact the person occupying the property
do we have can we have clarity on that
i don't think we actually would have an
answer for that chairman um we don't
know
may i check yes but it's the legal
advisor
may i um i'm hoping i can be heard and
that i'm visible
um yeah the um i need to ask the case
officer is the
the put it putting panels on the other
um
existing dwellings um the one-bedroom
units that were originally sheltered
would that be an act of development that
required planning permission i presume
it would be
they're already done the other
properties right okay but the
the the the changes that are um members
of express disappointments i mean the
other would they
are they acts of development that would
require planning permission
there is permitted development rights on
domestic properties
so so in fact that they don't need
planning i thought that was the case i
was just slightly confused by something
somebody said earlier but
so they wouldn't require planning
commission but now the next question is
is the
the rest of the development the rest of
the
the set of dwellings if i can use that
term um
where is the red line on this plan is it
is it just the common room and the land
that's needed to expand it
for this new dwelling yep that's right
also
so in that case there might be a
question about whether we lawfully could
impose a condition
um relating to uh things that are um
outside as it were outside the
application but the
the other dwellings have already got
solar panels on it's only this one we're
talking about
this one when you're talking about
putting panels on this proposal
sorry i got the wrong end i do apologize
wrong in the stick so in fact that would
be a
something that that that would yeah i'm
with you on that right
um okay well i'll leave it to the case
officer advise the committee on that
sorry i thought
i misunderstood something somewhere
so what can we or can we not condition
pv panels can we have an answer on that
please um was that to
me yeah yeah please there is nothing
stopping you
putting a condition on to say that
you're only going to find the
application satisfactory
if it has uh solar panels uh pv
on and if i was to try and support the
reasoning
for the condition i would direct members
to uh paragraph 148 and one
five 154a of the nppf uh that refer
to supporting as a planning system the
use of renewable
energies and recognizing that even
small-scale
development projects such as even a a pv
panel on a roof
uh has a benefit in respect of um
reducing carbon and greenhouse matters
thank you councilman do you want to go
sorry councillor um muller do you want
to go down that route as you proposed it
yes i'm happy with that chair thank you
okay and counselor mansell did you want
to second it
yeah now that we've got a condition
about pv panels
yeah okay thank you uh we'll keep going
to other members then so i've got
councillor ebern then councillor field
and councillor passmore
um thank you chair um i was going to
make the same point so um
that others have now made and um i think
it was very good to have um
glenn allen on the call explaining that
to us today because it's not clear from
the
from the papers so i appreciated um
that but you know i think this is a good
use of this
room and to make it or this unit as it
were to make it into two bed
and it's just a shame we don't sort of
maximize that through the um
pv as what has been discussed um
so other than that i'd be happy with the
application thank you chair
thank you councillor field uh
i think i i'm too i'm fairly happy
you know the questions have been asked
but could i just ask the legal officer
i did just lose my earth leakage breaker
just came out and i lost power
to the house so i missed a minute or two
or three of the meeting is it okay for
me to continue
uh right do we know which silly question
possibly do we know which minutes or two
who
g was discussing the possibility of a
um a condition uh on salah pv
well i think i think council i think
you've got the point you i think you
understand i mean normally
i'm very cautious about losing a member
even for a short time but i think
um if the governor's office agrees with
me i think if this if you i think you
you understand the essential point
that's been made in the last five
ten minutes of conversation i don't
think your ability to participate is
seriously prejudiced
could i just just just to mention if you
miss me mentioning
the the sport supporting factor for the
condition could be led
by paragraphs 148 and 154a
of the nppf that was the the fundamental
point i
made so as long as you're clear on that
now as i've just repeated it
uh i think you'd be okay in terms of
what you have said i'm indeed clear on
that thank you thank you very much
councillor
um nothing to add chairman i'm very
happy with what's proposed so i should
be supporting it
okay well on that basis we're now going
to go to the vote and i'll ask the chief
planning officer
to read out the proposal on the table
and then we'll ask the government's
office to conduct electronic vote
thank you chair um just before we go to
that point did we get i don't believe we
got a seconder
yes councillor mansell oh apologies i
wasn't that that was me
sorry apologies counselor mansell um
so i have in the recommendation that
the application be approved as detailed
in the office of recommendation with the
additional condition
for photovoltaic panels is that
acceptable mr payment g with that
wording
yes although can i add the words uh to
be agreed at the end
so that it is in the local authorities
interest to agree that the detailing and
location and so on so we need to have to
be agreed
i have added that thank you so chair if
you're happy for me to proceed
please thank you so if members could
please go
to the modern.gov app and go to the plus
sign on today's agenda and go to the
subsection on voting
and attendance and then go to the voting
tab and the vote will be
shown in progress as a light blue line
thank you
thank you cheer i have received all
votes discounting councillor mayors as
the account voters will remember that is
seven votes for and is unanimous
thank you very much okay we're going to
move on to the next application
dc210a122 the common room at victoria
gardens
watersfield back to you please afro
thank you chair
i'll just share my screen
if you could just confirm that you can
see the slides please
yes we yes we can brilliant okay so
similar to the previous application
the works haven't been completed under
the permitted development rights so the
application is for
full planning permission for the change
of use of the common room
to a general needs dwelling and the
erection of a single story extension
this application also seeks the creation
of a parking area
to serve the units the application
is to be determined by committee as mid
suffolk district council are the
applicant
and also in the land
so for the aerial image the application
site is within the village of
wattersfield
to the north of the site here is the
a143 which if you were to travel
west goes towards ickworth and berries
and edmonds
and then east towards this the
application site is accessed from the
highway of the street
which runs south through the village
the application site comprises of six
residential units within a single story
building
to the east of the building is
watersfield
community centre and recreation ground
and their residential
properties to the west and the south
so this is the site location plan and
site plan submitted with the application
the dark gray area shown on the plan on
the right depicts the common room
centrally within the building and again
the same applies
as with the previous application where
the common room
is now in as kind of a state of disuse
and is no longer required
so in terms of constraints um its
council-owned land as previously and
it's also within the settlement boundary
of wattersfield
it's also within wattersfield
conservation area
and there is a grade two listed building
to the south shown in orange here and
also
further north west
and just a note before we go through the
plans
um just to be clear with reference to
ria that is taken to be the elevation
facing the highway of the street
with the front being the single access
door which is
the other side so
this is the central gable to which
hosts the common room where the
extension is proposed
and the view of this gable from the
sides
this is the existing floor plan showing
the common room and the boiler room
and the unit also has a kitchen and
toilet
so this plan shows the proposed
extension which would have a pitched
roof with an eaves and ridge height to
match the existing building
the proposed materials would be concrete
pan tiles
and facing brickwork to match the
existing building
so this shows the extension from the
side elevations
it would protrude 3.4 meters from the
rear elevation
and fenestration is proposed to both
side elevations
and similarly the proposal is for the
change of use and extension to create
a two-bedroom general needs unit with
living room kitchen and bathroom
so this is a plan showing the suffolk
county council highway limits
with the green being the adopted highway
so you can see the access road from the
street is private
privately owned this is the
existing parking arrangement which is
currently just parking on the private
highway
the road is also used to access the
community centre
to the west um to the east sorry
and this is the proposal it's to provide
um
echelon parking um in the form of five
general use spaces and one disabled use
space
the on-road parking would remain the
hedge row to the east
is to be cut back or grubbed out to
facilitate the parking area and would be
replaced with a
0.9 meter high fence
so in terms of photos this shows the
units at victoria gardens
the extension is proposed to this
central gable here
and just a close-up of that central
gable with the common room there
so this is what we're referring to as
the front elevation with the
single access door and similarly the
double door for the boiler room
and this is the grassed area which is
proposed for the parking area
with the hawthorne hedge running along
the left of this photo
wattersfield parish council have raised
concerns regarding the removal of this
hedge so we are proposing an additional
condition
to mitigate this which i will cover
shortly
and then this is the same proposed
parking area with the hedgerow shown
here
so in summary the application seeks to
make good alternative use of the common
room
the conversion would provide a
two-bedroom general needs unit
the extension is small in scale and the
materials would match the existing
the proposal is not considered to have a
detrimental impact on the conservation
area
the parking facilities would provide a
betterment to the site
overall and the proposal is therefore
the recommendation sorry is therefore
for approval subject to the standard
time frame
and approved plans condition and a
condition to provide
the parking and maneuvering areas as
requested by the highways authority
and in addition to the conditions listed
in the report
it's recommended that a further
condition is imposed to ensure
that the hedge is retained or if this is
not possible the submission of details
of a replacement hedge is provided
thank you chair thank you very much
okay uh happy at cancer field you've got
your camera on just so you know
i'm happy to open this up to colleagues
for any questions
at this stage counselor mansell
thank you chair um can i just clarify
that when we're talking about the hedge
we are talking about that low thing that
was in your photo not the band of trees
that appeared to separate this plot with
the playing field
correct we aren't talking about getting
rid of those trees we're talking about
just dealing with that it's the
hawthorne hedge
uh councilmember
thank you um can i ask about the
large oil tank that is currently on the
site i assume because the boiler room's
going
and the um more modern heating systems
we put in
that tank will be removed
that question probably is also best
focused towards glenn
because i believe the same situation um
is happening here with air source heat
pumps but i will
i will be better yeah okay
thank you councilman
we'll come back to you glenn when we
come to your section okay
thank you jeff how's it going i just
wondered whether
if we're going to pave over um that
grassy area
for for car parking can we pave it with
with something which will actually allow
the water to
um penetrate rather than run off
that's for glenn as well really isn't it
yes it is and and
yeah or debate it's not really for
i mean we could we could uh what avra
what is proposed currently
let's ask that question
okay bear with me
i don't think we have specific details
of
um the material to be used but i would
assume it's um
a tarmac
that glenn might be able to give more
details on that
okay we'll come back to that uh any
other questions
councilman i think that's an old hand
any other questions at all no okay
so we will move on um to the applicant
we don't have a representative of the
parish council we don't have an object
or a supporter
but we do have glenn allen uh who has
three minutes to address the committee
please
over to you and if you turn your camera
on thank you
hello uh again with this proposal
it was something that was going to be
done very quickly under permitted
development
and hence there was going to be the
retention of
the plant room originally or the boiler
room
because uh again
historically all of the other buildings
are supplied their heating and hot water
supply comes from
this area because of the change in tack
again this was one of the ones that was
going to be in the phase two
it's now going to be done more
traditionally so we're doing
planning and building regulations and
tendering for the work
again as avril pointed out part of this
will be to
take a more holistic approach in the
development of this so the
boiler room will be and the development
of the living space will all become one
now
and the surrounding buildings will all
benefit from new air source heat pump
systems going in
again there's no gas in the village so
this is a
a good option and is renewable sorry
sustainable
um in respect of the old system being
taken out
the the oil tank and the plinth that it
stands on will be
removed as part of that works as well so
that the whole system will be
decommissioned
top to bottom uh in respect of
the parking that will be
put in using a permeable construction
so we have a material which allows
for the water to filter through
the the wearing course and into the sub
base so
that will be again a sustainable
solution to that and not require any
upgrade of the drainage
on site in terms of the hedge that runs
along that boundary line
i think perhaps the drawings are a
little bit misleading there in that
they're
kind of diagrammatic rather than
actually showing exactly what will
happen the
hedge is considerably smaller than shown
on the drawings
and there is no intention to take that
hedge out the only place
that is potentially going to be affected
is where the disabled base sits
as the ground or the line of the land
there does narrow very slightly
and the car parking bay gets quite close
to the hedge at that point
so there might need to be some
mitigation just at that point there but
other than that the hedge would simply
be cut back and retained
thank you very much uh okay questions
for the applicant do we have any
further questions
yeah councillor field
i just wondered as we're extending car
parking and doing various work in that
area whether we're
adding any uh electric car charging
points for our
residents there had been no intention to
do that
as part of this development
is that forward thinking and my other
question perhaps was
i'm sure you've checked but the
electrical supply to
what was sheltered accommodation is up
to
supporting uh the devices we require
which are
slt pumps
yes the uh as part of the works
there will be the need to put in a new
electrical supply into the building at
the moment
the existing plant room has a three-flat
three-phase
supply that will need to be stripped out
and completely renewed with a brand new
single-phase supply so sufficient
electrical
provision will be made
thank you any other questions at all
nope okay so we'll move on thank you
very much so we move over to the ward
member council mayor
thank you chair again very little to say
um
i'm delighted to see that the hedge
albeit not a very big one is being
retained
um a parking solution that required that
hedge to be ripped out
when we've got major oil tanks being
removed just
seem to be um to lack imagination so
it's it's a good
to see that being retained and i'd also
point out that the village hall has a
large car park
so visiting um parking spaces are
readily available so
there is really no need to remove that
hedge but generally the parish council
are supportive of this change thank you
thanks very much okay remember any
questions for the ward member
okay if not happy to open uh happy open
up for general discussion
and debate and to reach conclusion
counselor matheson
well i think all our questions have
recently been
answered already so i i think i would
propose approval
thank you uh councillor muller thank you
chair i'm happy to second councillor
matheson's approval
thank you anyone else wish to speak or
should we go to a vote
anyone else will speak no okay can we go
can you remind us please what we're
being asked to decide
and can the governance officer go to
conduct the electronic vote please
thank you chair um as it's um there's
been no change to the recommendation it
simply reads
that application dc210011
sorry double oh one two two be approved
as detailed in the officer
recommendation
but i will just amend that to say
updated officer recommendation in light
of what avril
has added yes thank you just to add the
the hedge
element yep so i'll just put the updated
so that all members are clear that
that's what that includes
so members the vote is now in progress
so if members could please go to the
modern.gov
app and go to today's agenda click the
plus sign in the top right hand corner
and go to the subsection on voting
attendance
there you will see from going on that
tab the light blue line
for the vote in progress as we're
getting further down the agenda you may
need to scroll down
thank you chair all votes have now been
received excluding councillor mayor as
he is the ward member so that is seven
votes for and is unanimous
thank you very much okay we now move on
to dc210a 101
in norton uh back to you again afro
please
thank you i'll just share my screen
again
so this is the final one of the of the
series um and this one they have
commit they have done the change of
works under the covet 19
emergency permit development rights so
the proposal
therefore seeks to retain these were
these works
so again full planning permission is
sought for
change of use of the common room to a
general needs dwelling
and parking upgrades
so the application site is within the
village of norton
this is the a1088
which heads north to itworth or south to
elmswell and wall pit
and the application site is accessed for
the street
which runs east west to the south of the
site
so the application site comprises of
seven single-story buildings
six of which comprise residential units
with the central one being the common
room
so you have norton primary school to the
north west of the site
and then residential properties to the
south and the west
this is the site location plan and site
plan submitted with the application
the dark gray area shown on the plan
on the right depicts the common room
in terms of constraints again the
application site is on council-owned
land
it is within the built-up area boundary
of norton
and school close is also a public
right-of-way which continues north along
the agricultural fields
so these existing elevations are pre
any covert permitted development right
so how it looked previously and i do
have some photos of that um so you can
see the changes
so there is fenestration to all
elevations
previously and the four floor plan um
previously was the common room kitchen
toilet and two store rooms to the top of
there
so this is the proposed elevation slash
current elevations
so there is no extension proposed to
this
building you'll note that the elevations
are largely the same
the alterations include changes to the
window arrangements
on the southern western and northern
elevations
the double access door has been changed
to a single access door
on this west elevation here and there's
also a new window which has been added
to the east elevation
which i believe serves a bedroom and
then
um black bat sorry black
hardy plank cladding has also been
applied to the areas where the glazing
and upvc panels have been
removed
so this is the proposed and current
floor plan
so the change of use would create a
permanent two bedroom
general needs unit with a living room
kitchen and two bathrooms
so in terms of parking provision the
previous parking provision was the small
lay-by to the west of the site which
hosts the
ambulance drop-off and disabled spaces
that's depicted in white in this plan
and the proposal is to create an
additional seven spaces
six of which are to be general needs and
one of which is to be
for disabled use so these additional
spaces would obviously reduce the amount
of on-road parking along school close
so in terms of photos this is the site
prior to the covert 19 works
um so the central building here with the
chimney is the common room it has the
white cladding
and the double entrance doors here and
you can just about make out
um kind of what the parking arrangements
were previously
so this is the current slash proposed
front elevation so you've got the change
to the single access door and the
application of black cladding
this is the northern side elevation
which is
largely the same and then this is the
east elevation with you can see the new
window
that's been installed here
and then the other side self-elevation
this is just another view of it prior to
the covert 19
works so the existing parking
arrangements
and then the final photo shows the
works of the parking as completed so
you've got the additional
four spaces here and then the free
spaces down the far end
in summary the application makes good
use of the common room
the permanent conversion would provide a
two-bedroom general needs
unit the external alterations are
limited to fenestration and cladding
the proposal would provide parking
improvements to benefit the whole site
so the recommendation is therefore for
approval subject
to standard time frame condition and
approved plans condition
thank you chair
thank you very much uh questions
counselor muller
thank you chair uh just one question i
noticed all the other
buildings on the site have white
cladding was there any particular reason
why this one's got black
cladding thank you
i don't know the specific um reason for
it being black i know that
i believe it was needed to be changed to
comply with building regulations
um but in terms of the color choice uh
i don't know why they why thank you just
just to comment thank you
okay any other questions counselor
mansell
uh can i can i just ask um how this
um dwelling is being heated
does it have a air source heat pump that
we've been talking about amongst the
other
the answer next if i don't know
yeah i'm not sure probably a glenn
question if that's okay thank you yeah
it's in the picture you showed okay any
other questions
nope okay so we'll move on um
so we don't have representative of the
parish council we don't have an object
or a supporter but we do have the
applicant so glenn allen
over to you and again three minutes
please
hello again uh this property was done
in phase one of the works and was
therefore developed
last summer and completed uh tail end of
the summer
the property was originally intended to
be converted
with the existing uh window arrangement
in place
but as it turned out these didn't comply
for several reasons
some of it to do with insulation and new
values some of it to do with security
and so the arrangement was changed to
a new set of windows in doing this
the opportunity arose to change the wall
layout
the original uh glazed and
clad sections were very old
and very poorly insulated so the
uh this gave us the opportunity to
actually bring these up to a much higher
standard
the reason that the cladding was black
is
this was deemed to be in keeping with
the remainder of the building there's
quite a lot of
black painted faces and soffits around
the other buildings and also on this
existing building and this was done
uh in conjunction with discussions with
planning so it wasn't
a unilateral decision by building
services this was something that was
done
in consultation the building is heated
by
an air source heat pump system the
existing building was fairly large in
size
and the internal layout was not amended
significantly
the existing hall was excuse me was
split into two bedrooms and a living
room
the parking at the front was addressed
at the time of the development
because school close in norton has
always been a pinch point because of the
school and because of
school leaving off times and the various
issues with parking there
it was deemed essential to deal with
this
as not only to address this development
to
but to also address the ongoing problems
in that area which it has done
and the provision of the additional
parking has exceeded
what was uh required for the development
in terms of space as there's an
additional parking space in there
which has alleviated significantly the
problems that did pre-exist
um other than that i think i've covered
the points
thanks very much any questions at all
yes councillor field is the ambulance
only parking space
still there and necessary does it say
the school as well or
do our residents need that could it be
deployed more usefully to alleviate the
other problems
that was deemed necessary to keep that
when we did the parking improvements
um the way that this was done is that's
part the original parking bay was part
of the highway which we had no
jurisdiction to work in
the uh the easiest way to achieve what
we needed to achieve was for us to put
in adoptable construction either side
but for that to be controlled by the
council going forward so that's a
maintenance item for the council
uh the only thing that we were allowed
to do was to change the white lining and
under guidance of highways we kept we
kept the ambulance bay
it was shrunk very slightly you will
have seen from avril's original
photograph that there was a very large
ambulance bay there and one
disabled space we were to able to shrink
that very slightly and end up with two
disabled spaces just there
predominantly the residents in the area
are elderly so it's deemed
that keeping the ambulance bay is
important
okay thank you thank you
councilor matheson yeah so
is this now general needs housing like
the others or is it shelter still
sheltered
this is general needs all right thank
you
okay we have no other questions so thank
you very much um
now wendy turner we thought might be
coming but i don't see her on the call
and harry richardson has given his
apologies and won't be speaking
so there are no ward members so i guess
it's over to us to discuss debate and
reach a conclusion
who would like to go first please uh
councillor mansell
uh thank you chair um as the um
one as the once award member of norton
i'm very much aware of this uh
this particular um area of norton
um and much as i don't like the uh
um you know to increase the amount of
parking excessively
it's always been a bowl of contention
with norton parish council about
parking on school road so um and these
particular
um this particular group of what was
sheltered housing is now general needs
housing
doesn't actually have any part didn't
have any parking at all
so the fact that i presume now each one
of those units
effectively has a parking space so long
as those parking bays are not abused by
parents
picking kids up from the school because
if you ever go through norton
at school pick up time you'll see the
cars are chaotic
all along the street which is is isn't a
particularly wide road
uh so i can i cut you know this has to
be supported this is a good scheme
it's put the common room into use um
it uh so i'd be happy to um
propose the um make me whatever it is
propose the uh recommendation the
recommendation that's the word i was
looking for thank you
uh yeah it's an asset to norton really
thank you
councillor miller thank you chair i'm
more than happy to second um
the the proposal made by councillor
mansell thank you thank you
uh councillor passmore uh thank you
chairman um
nothing to add apart from i think it's a
good scheme so i should be voting for it
thank you and councillor ebern um
sorry chair i was about to second so i
put my hand down the rush
the rush to second okay uh on that basis
i think we'll hand over to the
government's officer
to ask us for an electronic vacation to
remind us what we're being asked to
vote on please thank you chair so as per
the last one there are
this is to approve the details in the
office recommendation but there are no
updated conditions to go with this one
so it's solely what is in members papers
so i've now started the vote so if
members could please go to the
modern.gov app
click the plus sign in the top right
hand corner of today's agenda and go
go to the subsection on vote voting and
attendance
the application the vote is now in
progress
and it will be showing a light blue line
you may need to scroll down
and before i've even finished everyone's
finished so
that is carried chair unanimously thank
you
thanks very much okay thank you for that
so we're on to the last application
before us today dc
2005 double six five land at little
meadows from uh banyar's green in lax
field
now light had case officer catherine
hale over tube please
okay thank you i'll just share my screen
so you can view the presentation
and you'll see the presentation on the
screen
yeah we can see that thanks okay so
this application is for the
um direction of a new dwelling
northeast of blacksfield and you can see
here on the site location plan it has
previously been to committee it went to
committee b
on the 5th of february 2020
and members voted to go with officer
recommendation of approval subject to a
number of conditions
this application basically seeks
just to old an alternative scheme um
mostly changes to the fenestration which
i'll show a bit later on
um as well as the the roof materials and
the the access point has changed but
otherwise the principle has been
established
previously so this is just the aerial um
street view to chasse the barn in its
immediate surroundings
and just a obviously zoomed out image um
it's
just slightly further down the barn is
actually situated on this corner but
also you can see
lacks field over here
constraints map as you can see there's
no actual constraints there is a
footpath to the south of a site
but the the site isn't actually
constrained by anything
this is the proposed block plan so you
can see the barn here
parking spaces and this is obviously the
access off of the the unnamed road off
because so this is the barn
as existing
and these were the previously approved
plans
um and the next slide will show we'll
see a few of
the changes so it's mostly two of
fenestration so there's an addition of a
new window here
um they're removing a window that was
previously approved here
um and making the windows slightly
larger
as well as the bifold doors so just to
make it clearer again this is what was
previously approved
this is what is now proposed so you can
see addition of the window here
the fenestration is slightly larger
bifold doors are slightly larger
southwest elevation you can see it's
you know more or less the same again
just fenestration is slightly bigger and
the addition of when
the removal of the window here
and same again so this window is
slightly larger
but otherwise the amount of fenestration
on this elevation
has not changed and again
southeast elevation so that the proposed
administration is slightly bigger
but otherwise it's still in the same
place
so the proposed access has changed
originally from
the previously approved scheme it was
off a private road a private track here
it is now proposed to be basically
in existing shared access um highways
are happy with this um and visibility
displays
meet their requirements
so the recommendation is approval
subject to
the conditions which are set out in the
bundle thanks very much
okay do we have any questions
at all on what's been presented
nope okay no no questions
okay so we'll move on um we don't have
the parish council we don't have an
object we don't have a support we don't
have the agent and we don't have the
applicant
the ward member is councillor judy
flatman who has given her apologies but
he has indicated support for
the proposal via an email
and that is it so members it's over to
us to discuss and debate
and to reach a conclusion
councillor muller thank you chair um in
view that the parish council have no
objections the ward member does have no
objections
i would recommend approval as stated in
the papers thank you chair
thank you very much councillor passmore
uh i would like to second it
to second uh councilman's proposal
chairman thank you
thank you anyone else wish to speak
nope okay i'm going to hand over to the
governance officer to please remind us
what we're being asked to vote on and to
take an electronic vote
thank you chair so if so the
recommendation
for this application is um as set out
in the papers with no amendments so i
will start the vote now
so if members could please go to the
modern.gov app and go to the plus sign
in the top right hand corner
and go on the voting tab the vote is now
in progress
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and that is
unanimous vote for thank you very much
okay final item on the agenda do we have
any site inspection requests that needed
to be reported to the committee please
an unreceived chair okay well thanks
everyone for joining us
thank you very much see you at planning
referrals on friday
and we